who's that girl shooting guys zombie
guys
[Music]
she's got good style I always wrap my
sweater on my ways too it's stylish but
it's also just smart because you're
gonna need it
it makes a lot of sense
[Music]
we did it we made it we made it to
nemesis you guys thought we couldn't do
it but we did I thought you couldn't do
it people seem to have more confidence
than I did thanks guys
Mary here with my buddy Mike McCarty
we're going to play Resident Evil 3 on
our journey to play through all Resident
Evil's this is nemesis new game starting
now I'm feeling really good about it
hard mode hard mode hard mode sure I'm
excited because I've only ever beaten
this game I think once or twice in my
life so it's gonna be very fresh I won't
be able to guide you as much but
whatever racoon okay that's what people
call it yep
dare to oppose them and that lack of
strength would ultimately lead its
raccoon
I suppose they had to suffer the concert
their actions
no forgiveness
if only they had had the courage to
fight
it's true that once the wheels of
justice begin to turn nothing can stop
them nothing
it was returned city's last dam saying
that struck in my last escape
so naturally I put on this outfit
brother I put on my survival tube-top
from a $500 do
whoa what are they
much more detailed yeah it's awesome to
watch the graphical improvements I think
that one had a j.crew vest on they're
considering style now
dan hobbies wearing Uniqlo this is like
a movie
Oh in the head you [ __ ] idiots didn't
you play resonable to just just all-out
mayhem
take take this is great it's like the
best montage of police not surviving you
want some more it is a pretty good
tribute to police sucking at their jobs
although I don't know if that was in
their job description killing zombies
yeah I mean nobody was prepped for that
it was that one guy's first day on the
job Leon it looks like your party's been
canceled not only is she wearing the
tube top she's got her like sweatshirt
oh me gleefully tied around her waist
I've started yeah I would just dodge I
do remember it's kind of like resonable
twos beginning or you could kill him I
got bullets move it or lose it
it's a dumpster oh my god that outfits
delightful where did you get it oh crap
I'm screwed yes yes now this is easy I
didn't do that
September 28 daylight the monsters have
overtaken the city it's true oh nice
it's true mister how many days was that
dear diary I am Alive I [ __ ] in a bucket
okay we've gotta get out of here what do
you think you're talking about who's
that guy outside conformant John Goodman
but there isn't gonna be any rescue we
have to get out of here because he's a
large man yeah no tell you anyway the
same rumbling baritone voice I'd rather
starve to death in here than be eaten by
one of those undead monsters Oh some
good acting someone you think I feel
like the acting went up a notch so far
maybe yeah Leon he's dead like that guy
gave a [ __ ] yeah I guess so hey I'm just
good
so let's okay eights Locke actually uh
read the I do remember some things I
don't read these no part of them yeah
use game instructions this explains
about the various actions operations on
map screen and operations in the event
scenes now use that thumb through all of
it okay
we hope you improve your chances to
survive
haha thank you thanks game you get
different reactions from shooting
objects such as oil drums and bombs okay
press the r2 button to aim directly at
these objects okay that makes okay
you can perform quick 180 degree turns
press run button while retreating when
you are trapped by enemies you can push
them away press directional buttons
action buttons cancel button run button
R 1 R 2 O 2 just [ __ ] freak out just
just punch the controller before an
enemy attacks you can perform a dodge oh
is that new press r1 or r2 or the press
the action button while aiming so the
180-degree turn is that you didn't have
in to is that you had in remaster you
did not happen to his package press I'd
like to practice that yeah you can get
on or off certain objects appear that
appear in the game press action button
while you are moving forward to edge of
an object why already had to do that
press l2 to view the map you can zoom in
by pressing the action button that's
nice
press select button to switch between
Maps okay there's a lot screen fades
into black and white these points you
will be prompted to choose between two
different options use the directional
buttons to move between the options and
make the act and the action button you
choose it is possible to skip certain
scenes press select button to skip those
scenes OOP done wait so what's this it's
just saved to your like documents got it
it's another tab with a next step or
file okay I would like to get out of
that got it it was triangle we're
learning Shai read this one too yeah
okay
creation of bullets how it's made to
create various ammunition you need to
use the reloading tool and gunpowder
this is necessary item if you want to
create different types of ammunition by
combining gunpowder and reloading tool
various types of ammunition will be
created mixed materials to create
various types of ammunition there are
three types of basic gunpowder's a b and
c please note that gunpowder c is
created by mixing a and b okay
got it okay how to mix gunpowder you can
create various types of bullets by
mixing different gunpowder's there are
13 different kinds of gunpowder's holy
crap
yeah it's complicated ah I don't want to
throw this away I need this a is handgun
bullets B shotgun shells C grenade
rounds and C's grenade flame rounds it B
and C is grenade acid rounds I'm not
gonna read through all these because
we're gonna have to go through these um
if you combine certain types of
gunpowder with grenade you get special
grenades so yeah you can reference this
later
yeah this is crazy totally different
that's your reloading tool next to your
handgun I believe what
that's your reloading tool to the right
next to the handgun oh and I need this
yeah I remember I usually kept it in my
inventory box and just like did ammo in
the save rooms okay okay I feel pretty
good um I only have 11 bullets cuz I
shot that zombie but I had no shower
this area no regrets
oh I'd like to practice my turns okay so
uh back in circle I think oh I know that
back in sprint button I thought it was
back in sprint button my sprint button
is square yeah will you I got it
okay so it's directional and then Square
and then I don't think you could dodge
and listen as Abhi's actually attacking
you that could be wrong if an r1 or art
it's kind of nice moonwalk action though
that I got going on here
press r1 or r2 without raising your
weapon uh sorry our one or our two
without raising your weapon oh um okay
our two I think will make me shoot I'll
do it
mows the dodge sure are the instructions
lining up it LT was my mastery I
remember that l1 does nothing and I
think r2 1 and R 2 at the same time
maybe I think that'll make me shoot
right r1 in our - yeah
wait would that I forgot the Dodge what
they said how they said Dodge we could
look at it I just wonder if it's
different on the
he's pissed three I go to file oh cool
and then the blue one yeah for so many
sheets of things that I need to know um
uh not escape r1 or r2 okay so it must
be when an enemy is near and then press
the action button while aiming I'm
impressed I didn't tell you to do that
yes you did there's the action button
while aiming that's what I did
oh that's what they told you do I don't
know there's the shoot but no wait
there's stuff back there yeah it's still
Tony's nice okay defective
I love defective products considering
we're starving OOP that stuff I see that
stuff give me that stuff whoo darn right
[ __ ] it's bread oh no I had said that I
know what it means what it is um oh
there was a red light over here is that
something it's on that i-beam this no
just yeah
what about it oh this button mm-hmm that
were you talking about no I signed what
oh there's like red blinky lights all
throughout this place like see that in
the corner in the upper right but it
wouldn't let me click on it so I don't
think that's thing um there's this guy
he's mad at me some good acting okay so
I'm going up the stairs oh I don't have
to hit the action button no but zombies
can chase you up and down stairs now oh
really
they're not like and they're they can do
more than just throw up from what I
remember on this day Hey
now that song stuck in my head well she
is
she just system so it was safe room huh
I saw that I saw that sparkle Sparkle
Sparkle will you take the warehouse key
must open some sort of car or warehouse
or something
the jokes get better as the series go on
no delivery voucher book but it won't
let me pick it up that's weird
yes I'm better a so that's handgun
powder so I should take it mm-hmm should
I try to make a gun here's how you can
uh should I take both of these maybe I
should keep one here or but come back
here take it you gotta save box right
underneath you um oh right so you could
make handgun bullets right now if you
want which might be advisable since you
don't have any other weapon yet okay so
I think you just combine the reloading
tool
yeah let's practice so ah you don't have
combined it out those bastards
no sometimes they change things for the
worse oh that happened really fast yeah
now you just combine yeah come VIN there
you go
and then maybe save the a in case for
later sure um I will put that in my oh
there's a knife in here that's not a
knife
I'll see you fight knife a spoon II but
I wouldn't carry the reloading tool
around oh okay I know I mean like it's
not like in cases where you could it's
not like I'm gonna be making anybody's
different summon krebons there oh yeah
it's right there you but I don't know if
you won't even save yet well I don't
really want to do this intro again or do
you think I'll be fine you'll be fine
because I don't you could speed through
that intro worst case scenario well I
did put it on hard mode
oh no the naming conventions are weird
like it's easy it's either easy or hard
I think heart is more akin to normal
don't call me on that well I feel pretty
good I have this key I think it's gonna
open up that door should we go yeah
into the raccoon city into the raccoon
city over King City you've changed city
of love the Windy City do you know what
I'm doing looking for Chris cuz she
heard about this [ __ ] after the mansion
incident from what I understand yes cuz
there's gonna be a bunch of [ __ ] out
here I start dodging some [ __ ] no buts
but you're in the city a lot more in
this game like urban environments cool I
actually liked that about the last game
and I I think the puzzles are nice but
going over the same areas again and
again and again like it's cool to like
mix it up maybe and do more out outtie
Dori areas it sounds like yeah doesn't
look like anything to me oh I hear some
[ __ ] hey
man the noise of like zombies in the
background but not you know like there's
the noise of zombies that are near you
mm-hmm but this just has a background
howl of like zombies in the distance mmm
Syd's sorry
hasn't it I couldn't like
what am i doing oh [ __ ] they're coming
after me should I shoot him
[ __ ] you love your stream of
consciousness I even say anything
hey yeah it's the only way you can go no
I bet there's more but this was the
first door I saw they're gonna be right
around this corner
back it up I just dodged you can get
around him behind them okay
knives of crap you're good you dodging
wants you the maps hot dogs hmm I left
those locked dang he came down those
stairs fast he did um I also noticed
that came down the [ __ ] mission
alright I need to look at the map
because there was like eight things that
I walked past in there like where did I
even come from you came from
that's the warehouse right from the red
alleyway so could have gone left or into
that room okay so you could kill them or
dodge them and go check that room out I
feel like I should kill them I know
you're going back there you might oh
I'll tell you what I think I learned
from the last one which was it's more
important to spend the ammo than to lose
your life multiple times yeah
so if I go through there a lot I'd
rather just kill them because it's just
not worth getting attacked more than
once
oh those plans go for it is that what I
think it is or those just I don't think
those are green herbs yes what you mean
they were like weed plants
oh the DeLorean
you hear that yeah someone needs my help
well you got that quick turn now
remember oh right the quick turn makes
me walk backwards is there [ __ ] near
them can I run past them yeah that's a
useful skill too dang the fan your
[ __ ] fasts sorry [ __ ] you're on your
own can I get in here
crap oh damn
alright I'm gonna I'm gonna try again
sorry let me go like bless my reset mo
what okay sue me kill me I'm gonna kill
these guys then you know the choice is
right here yeah that's right get down
get up - get down
that's right stay down alright there's
another one where are you try yourself
I like my shoe Depot's very Oh No
get down get down get down
oh my god um man they came out of that
room so I can afford it I got bullets
and outfits for days - don't make me put
my crop top on cool pile of dead zombies
and I didn't even get a mark on my boots
let that be a lesson to you alright this
room I think mmm double-check that looks
ominous
map it up yeah so why you go down then I
[Music]
should have used my um evade idiot oh
crap
yeah to the shotgun in that man's belly
and maggots all over get up get up
dan I give it to you right away
when idiot he died with bullets
you take the lighter oil yes that sounds
important now in the last game I just
had a lighter on me at all times
mmm did hélène Jill starts with one of
the first no she doesn't
Chris does yeah I have a lottery
lockpick Leon's
cases of drinking water can't take him
them he's lucky he died before his guts
were ripped out oh yeah I guess he's
lucky he died without his face being
blown off oh wait
not everyone can be lucky all right so I
think there was a little place here
knives should I take them yeah say so
oh wait how's my health okay guys take
those and double back to the city
warehouse saver and box just for the
future I think I could I think I could
I'm gonna I'm gonna investigate this and
I'm a backtrack all right crap crap crap
all right I'm gonna reset I got it
the zombies were not resetting them oh
they weren't a few times I don't know if
they do that in this game like watch he
wasn't which makes it tough because cuz
that's one of my favorite track
decisions yeah not maybe he did all
right so I want him to be over here god
he's fast all right Tim right now on him
you go down into that bar right there in
here I could be wrong come that looks
like a door yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that's blocked off yeah who's that
curbs up in that fire escape um where no
paddle oh yeah right there
get up but can they get up here
I don't know idiot
I hope not check out my sweet moves you
wish you had this move dum-dum wish you
had the fall I'm for pata what's that
nothing she said like pick up that her
boobies didn't color that's her name now
um she even looks pensive in her photo
yeah I'm cold
oh is that it
oh no cuz all those guys are down there
cuz I I thought there would be a
different way to go I didn't think this
through there's gonna be like eight
dudes there mm-hmm and I'm almost out of
bullets and I didn't might have time to
drama one side
I didn't bring my bullet maker yeah you
have the shotgun like worst case
scenario obviously I want to use that
possible but trying to get him to one
side maybe and then sprint down where am
I going that way you think like down the
alley or should I leave I think it's a
dead end that way I'm checking map if
you want oh right my map smart no it's a
way to go um what do you think I could
go back the way I came there's still so
much I haven't seen I'm actually
confused with which way is the way to
progress the game now because I don't
want to go too far yeah go uh and you
don't know because you've only picked
this game twice and you don't have the
knowledge that I need
yeah okay look so look yeah so you
didn't like there's a lot I haven't done
here yet
what's the door you did go through don't
remember so those are locked that one is
a maybe could it be locked yeah there's
a lot of guys down there look I think
that's the way to progress because like
there's locked doors here so that mean
leads me to believe we're going to get
around the other side of those so in
your professional opinion should I go
back the way I came or should I try that
door I would go back the way you came
okay
okay because you had your inventories
almost full out so go all the way down
the alley take a left take a right got
it
okay here we go feeling
you could probably well you may shoot
him I mean yeah I don't leaguer to get
by him yes I am without sure oh my oh
I added one oh crap oh crap oh crap okay
so I didn't I didn't know that they were
gonna do that huh yeah I would I would
risk the one shotgun shell
oh well go go go go go yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and now judge wait where
am I going oh my god oh my god I'm going
to the right you might as well come
right now
see I think the rice blocked off I would
just stay calm come a little toward the
camera and it's gonna draw some dudes
stay along the building and then go
right and dodge so wait right dodge mah
my writer the Jill's read you you're
right you're like ah what which way am I
going you me go that way or that way I
don't know just whichever like it looks
like you could you'd be better off going
this way now we go towards the alley
uh-oh you can dodge those dudes now yeah
nice yeah oh my God if this is locked
I'm so [ __ ]
nice why is that like door medieval the
tavern cellar I have not
done very well it's getting annoying to
here's our man G okay okay rosters run
do that so unlike us
yeah unlock it it's red it's that was
one of the ones locked in the other side
you're already on the other side so do
that I would recommend
now the other shortcut okay so that's
good nice so that's a big shortcut
already since I would just go back to
the safe room yeah get you rigged cuz I
get those I can collect more herbs oh
[ __ ]
where am I good Dodger
I didn't it's all right where am I going
left to right I forget this is my
problem
um so I'm going towards that Dom that's
pretty crazy that way try to go that
door so I'm taking a left I'm super
confused now behind you and then the
left like the opposite direction then I
left man
yeah there and then yeah oh man and then
there's two herbs along here but I would
deposit those all this room you now like
I'm super like forgetful yeah but I mean
like by the end of two you knew the
police station pretty that's right but
okay yeah so collect these well you'll
have room for one right well I might
actually need to use one now no I'm
actually still okay mm-hmm okay I in the
first days spray I don't know why I kept
it cuz I didn't know where I was going
okay so I'm going back the way I came
mm-hmm
this isn't going that bad no you got
stocking up oh you know what I never
investigated this area so I'm just gonna
do it right now
crap yeah you know ken anyway after you
come back out there zombies all over the
place I changed my MA
no respite wait
I killed everybody in here are you in
the warehouse right now I thought I was
mmm
this doesn't make any sense I thought
this was the warehouse yeah well yeah
that could have changed yeah you are has
changed so who's that guy just some dude
that reanimated their zombies look it's
a guy you've changed
Jill more like Jill Halloween is can I
dodge that guy ya think so
Oh idiot he vomited on his lady oh you
did dodge him originally he was there I
did yeah dad I'm good
warehouse was unnecessary mm-hmm like
any time I think you're getting to call
more confident I have to we just yell at
me hey things up it'd be nice to find a
save room that's further along
like I don't want it to come back here
every time oh yeah you're not gonna have
to okay so best should I make some
shotgun bullets shells I think is you
don't you can't you don't have a be
gunpowder I could also combine these
eggs now I shouldn't do that
I'm just saving for now should I keep
want something I probably I'll get rid
of first dates break because there's
that green herb still in the alleyway oh
so I'll just collect that I don't think
you need a lighter fleet feel right now
but I could be very wrong I'd rather
have it then I would feel more
oh [ __ ] I think you're good on ammo I
would save that gunpowder a for now
really cuz yeah if you get actually I
don't even have gunpowder B that's I'm
saying you can't make shotgun rounds yet
I don't really have that many bullets
like they're being pretty cruel with
bullets right now 23 decent number for
killing for you yeah I mean you can
combine them oh and I'm saving yeah are
you I've gotten pretty far mm-hmm really
yeah come for if you want I think you've
been doing fine I don't think you need
safe
I don't want to read you it's been at
least a half hour
bro it didn't autosave after the intro
that's right it's been a half hour about
yeah but you feel confident my abilities
yeah
wait did you save I did over the old
save yes why because it didn't autosave
I tested to see if the game would save
because last time when we played
Resident Evil 2 it couldn't save and we
lost just lie to me that that was an
autosave yes you wait so where'd you get
the first Ingram and then are you
started I started a new game gotcha ok
interesting lying to me i lying it was
like a me it was like a passive live
fabric of resin Knievel is already
unraveling and we haven't even barely
started three it was because I didn't
think it through
I'll take kindly to deceit you're my
favorite
[Music]
can't interesting dynamic developing
here
the Messi has become the messer it's
like oh god about him I forgot I forgot
here that's what you get
yeah mm-hmm I won't I would just reload
that safe now if you should fine but
seriously that's what you get for lying
um [ __ ] I got an caution from that demon
could wipe go back that say if you want
really quick I can't easily I don't
think use die
alright let's investigate this area
restart the console yeah but I'm not
gonna do it for nothing
oh this is all a huge loop mm-hmm you're
missing that herb and then Ellie and
actually you can go around and go back
Yakko that's why I'm killing myself Oh
Ari I thought so I don't have to
whatever let's just rolled it where am I
going
go that way the herbs that way no I
passed the Europe now cuz that little
loop it's vosch I'm confused
it's gonna be to your right there up
here and then to your right yeah this is
the only place where I've killed the
zombies
so what haven't I done I think it'd be
safer haven't gone in there I think well
right but I think it would be safer I
think you should try out that yellow
door in the middle cuz that'll lead to
the boutique in the bar like the back
and they're probably stuff in there
because that looks like that's the end
of that no no no to your left
yeah that one because that leads to the
other side of those lock doors and that
I kind of assume that's not going to
progress you in the game but there's
probably stuff to find like health and
whatnot but what is the safest way to
gain that first door you pointed to
rather than going through the really
popular alleyway go through here and go
down the stairs yes alright that other
way to the left is crawling with zits
Syd's zombies in the distance there well
now I know did you make that up no you
said zombies in the distance really I
said yeah SIDS
CID zombies in the distance as ID's I
never even collected that if I you just
said something weird do I do that often
yes all right straight through no
problem
dodged idiot and I hit that pole idiot
she's looking back she runs into this
you big time we're doing sorry I have to
keep doing this because I do not
understand where I am yet like I don't
get the placements just yet yeah you're
left there zombie then down the stairs
yeah and then is there a zombie down
there I think so yeah Oh train okay okay
shits gonna go down here no no save save
room
[Music]
oh you did Brad check out the big brain
on bread wait wait wait wait I'm yeah
Dukey kills him oh I think yeah okay
sorry
Brad hanging slow dancing a crowd
against someone doing something about
the John Mayer song I didn't know you
were still alive Jill the police aren't
trained for this kind of situation what
could they do what were you saying about
the voice acting listen he's coming
oh I'm fine I'll get up we're gonna die
whoo what are you saying
you'll see
he's gonna shout the stars members
there's no escape people are so elusive
every time you have a friend here they
like bail yeah they just like leave me
oh I saw shiny see you huh I'll come
convinced that [ __ ] the fuel in the
lighter oil and the lighter sorry oh
right that's a good idea come VIN cool
can i play these cool beer cool beer man
cool beer I'm [ __ ] behind a bar I like
to assume that they mean that socially
the beard is just really good and
fitting in pretty hip it looks like you
picked that thing up on the bar yes I
agree
a picture of a postcard of a clock tower
following explanation is printed on the
backside a landmark spot saint-michel
clock tower okay with October 26 Marty
and Doc were nice cruising down the
DeLorean all bourbon I will shut yes I
was super excited about more bullets I
really need more bullet checking the
back side of bar I'd say okay did you
say back side because I can put on some
jeans shorts partially consumed food
that deers like fog
how does it feel to become the haunted
yeah you know the nemesis yeah I can't
wait yeah I've never played this before
so I don't know anything about him but I
have seen like some Inklings of his
existence my stomach's gurgling
okay okay this was the one I couldn't
get into but this is the heavily
populated area that's really dangerous
uh-huh
I know the boutique door is still just
locked so I guess the question is is
where we going now top o to that door so
I could go this way in the danger zone
or I through the safer area I could go I
could turn around and go back through
this door and go through here yeah that
too
I think I'll do that make sense
working on my quick turn I haven't
evaded one zombie I don't think I
understand how to do it maybe it's about
the timing I don't know if I ever did
that it was our one right r1 or r2 it
said it's confusing um okay so I'm going
up these stairs to the left
no straight right up the stairs straight
and there's totally zoms in this area
sure I'll let you have it
I was another one in there I know you're
going I see it
nice I feel like the totally planned
calculated lock door ah [ __ ] you
so this alley is dead end
is that not a joke uh can I get on that
oh I think I'm on this part alright I
can actually help you out of over here
if you need yeah okay uh wait for them
to get that wheel barrel and shoot it
okay too many as possible okay I would
do it now so you don't focus on a zombie
uh okay I don't know how to shoot the
oil just shoot just like shoot it I
think it should I mean you might have
waited too long now I hope you didn't
cuz that killed a lot of zombies um we
have to rearranges just tried shooting
Hey oh my god my heart hey guys I was
worried you were gonna focus on a zombie
instead of the barrel so I think this
was just silly of me I thought that if I
hit r2 I automatically shot at the
nearest thing and that's not know you
got raised that Web
dammit
nice okay um I don't know if I was meant
to kill all those guys I don't think I'm
gonna pass this fire hey yeah I can yeah
you're good
early skirt the building
my bet yeah oh yeah oh stuff at the end
then red nice I just combined that I
will I will convince
my first explosion mm-hmm I learned a
lot nice there's that door but that's
locked photo uh
it's weird it's my birthday well
September 20 seconds my birthday but his
flesh was apparently bitten off or
devour did it people are eating people
or they have a leprosy so this one is
locked
oh I can burn it yeah - wait that rather
you're home alone you smell that
yes kerosene the ropes soaked in it now
why would anyone stoke a rope in
kerosene well up here you big horse's
ass go back go back there screams
they're fine they were such brilliant
Christmas movies just get the [ __ ]
kicked out of them I don't feel good
about that noise do you hear it it is
weird yeah Oh God it's dogs okay dogs my
other nemesis present evil three big
canines
was the best I came up with like I said
I'm tired in the jokes we'll get back at
Cana what would you prefer just know it
looks like you will be backtracking
through here so East OS just kill them
and then you can decide later all right
because you're gonna come back through
here okay well then I am going to get my
bullets ready or should I have a shotgun
no I think the handgun stumbles them in
this game from what I remember you see
that I did there there to your left
they are I [ __ ] hate every time I have
dogs there's a fork in the road they do
this on purpose
I hear you oh I see them Oh mmm
they're jumping in the left go that's
what you said [ __ ] out of the flames
actually ya know go through go through
well you [ __ ] well now when you come
back through he'll have a better you
could just use that combined
if you're in red [ __ ] well date yeah
that's what we need so we're the [ __ ]
mine this is the new areas uh I would
just go back and kill his dog to check
out the rest area first thing to just
save room sometime soon I would hope so
oh my goodness maybe not though well all
these shortcuts you might actually be
fine going back to the warehouse cuz you
cleared out most of zombies in that one
path you know I mean I need to hear them
reload please pause and reload I think
you got the second one oh my god that
was your last bullet I can't do it [ __ ]
them up
ooh that looks pointy
so yeah I think you would actually with
the shortcuts you cleared out in the
path you cleared of zombies you might
just save in the warehouse I I mean like
check out the rest later sorry keep
accidentally clicking on this okay here
we go
now there's another door right here
there's three so there's one right here
into the flame one yet without the fire
oh right got it totally yeah that makes
sense
yeah I wonder if this is the kind of
game where it only gives you one save
whoa well then what's on the shelf right
there paint or gunpowder yeah
oh shut gunpowder B who's yellow shotgun
saw it what if it's like gunpowder [ __ ]
you mm-hmm so that's shotgun I could
combine it with a to make C or I could
make shotgun bullets yeah well let's see
again I can't remember good look up the
manual if you feel like it yeah I mean I
would I would do shotgun rounds ah at
this point let's just remember it's fine
and by remember I mean read it cuz we
don't remember all of a sudden oh my god
I know now grenade you don't okay so I
don't really have need grenades though
although like they sound nice
whoo CCC is Magnum Magnum
um I think shotgun shells the most
important thing right now I would yeah
but I wouldn't even bother like that's
what you want to do like save up until
you really know because then by the time
you get you have like a [ __ ] ton of A's
and B's you can make magnum rounds later
right should other ink ribbons in here
ah there might be yeah I would save this
stuff you should be able to put a on a
oh wait no well I'm afraid I don't know
I'm afraid I'm not doing out oh I could
combine these okay I'll do that
and then I'll probably keep that yeah
now I haven't needed not only that you
don't have like any shotgun rounds I
would take the shotgun for now the
lighter I can't see that's the thing
that's like I needed it for that Rosie
on what you need
yeah should I say you're not wandering -
I would save you haven't saved in a
while or I don't know if you want to
save you only have to increment left I
would just go when are we playing the
next episode I don't know let's talk
about it we could just you could just
chill here we could end the episode now
that was about an hour and then okay
make sure no one turns ps3 off okay and
then just come back later
not saving so it's kind of saving but
yeah we could do that sweet cool that
was the first episode of Resident
knievel 3 3 nemesis nemesis sequel
I haven't the third game ultimate
nemesis a room marathon next episode
probably my nemesis what when will I see
my nemesis
you're getting there I mean no rush
yeah he is thanks for watching guys
don't forget to Like and subscribe so we
can keep making these things cuz because
that's how it works
we'll see you in a few days but Mary
I'll see you in like 20 minutes
kabaah Donald that makes a weird noise I
hate it